ukraine's president vladimir zelinski is
again appealing to russian president
vladimir putin to sit down and talk in
hopes of ending russia's brutal and
intensifying war against ukraine
as russian forces now target the
outskirts of the western city of la vie
zielenski is accusing russia of creating
a humanitarian catastrophe by blocking
critical supplies to his country's
largest cities the u.n estimates six and
a half million people have been
displaced by the war so far coupled with
more than three million who fled ukraine
and the battle is also extending
offshore ukraine's defense minister says
russian troops are blocking access to
the azov sea which connects to the black
sea it renews concerns that a widening
war could be imminent chris livesay
begins our coverage in odessa in
southern ukraine chris good morning
good morning jeff it is here on
ukraine's coastline that russian forces
have been advancing but in the eastern
city of harkeef ukrainian forces have
been holding firm in the face of
ferocious russian shelling
no neighborhood is safe in ukraine's
second largest city these apartments
where hundreds of thousands still live
are the front line svetlana blocks out
what she can
i'm very grateful for our soldiers
defending our land she says hold on guys
we'll always support you
for more than three weeks russia has
tried and failed to break through the
city across ukraine the pentagon
estimates more than 7 thousand russian
troops have been killed so far overnight
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
appealed directly to moscow time to talk
he said it's time to restore territorial
integrity and justice for ukraine
otherwise russia's losses will be such
that it will take you several
generations to recover
but vladimir putin is not projecting an
image of compromise vowing russia will
prevail at this packed rally though many
attendees told reporters they were under
pressure to come out in support of him
putin reiterated his claim that
ukrainian civilians had welcomed
russia's troops but the heartache tells
the truth
in keeve a son cries over the body of
his mother
killed by falling debris and in mariupol
the scene of russia's most vicious
onslaught an entire city encircled in
siege warfare leaving hundreds of
thousands of civilians trapped without
food water heat and electricity russia
says it's now tightening the noose on
the strategic city on the black sea
even deploying islamist troops from its
chechen region
this video purportedly released by
chechnya's pro-putin leader shows them
engaging with ukrainian fighters
positioned in the upper floors of this
building but ukrainian forces here are
not without victories of their own this
drone footage shows them hitting a
russian armored vehicle and an invading
soldier trying but failing to flee
now here in odessa on the black sea
coast the city is fortifying its
defenses learning lessons from mariupol
trying not to befall the same fate now
just over the horizon russian warships
have been spotted even lobbing missiles
into nearby towns michelle
chris thank you and be careful out there